I actually got a message from my brother
that I kind of know here is the message
that was sent by his wife's friend who
is a female okay so here is how it goes
you need to answer now it's very
important don't do the deed meaning do
not consummate the marriage see this
period is getting to know period should
married couples have such single friends
what do you guys make it out so it's not
whether she is single whether she is
divorced is women in general that's the
issue here imagine if the wife done what
many women do do of take your friends
wise imagine she'll start you know what
for real I'm gonna make him wait oh my
God
this is how my runes are born this is
how like red pill movements are born bro
I don't think you should have anyone
involved in your marriage regardless of
who is whoever it's your friends your
mom your dad your brother your cousin I
don't think anyone should have an
opinion on your marriage because it's
your marriage it's no one else's
marriage it's your marriage and secondly
it is a problem amongst the women Muslim
women do talk to their friends about
personal issues that they should
students it doesn't matter who it is
whether it's your best friend your mum
your dad psychologist it doesn't matter
take it with a pinch of salt because
that person is not in your shoes only
you know your situation if your friends
are gonna emotionally blackmail you by
saying that you know if you don't tell
us the style well I'm gonna be friends
with you then you just with the wrong
friends to begin with as a man I
wouldn't want to play tug of war with my
wife you know going back and forth like
her friends are secretly telling her
things and yeah I'm gonna feel like I'm
playing tug of war sex to a man is love
yes when you're taking away that love
you're taking away an integral part of
that relationship guaranteed that advice
from her friend was going through her
mind when that was meant to be one of
the most blessed your sacred pure times
that she was ever meant to experience in
her whole life if if somebody told him
don't give give love to your missus well
bro that'd be World War II there would
be World War II
oh
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a sadakhajari for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you and the shall American award click
the link and donate what you can
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are well inshallah welcome
to another episode of The Bitter truth
show uh before I start I want to praise
Allah the most merciful the most
trustable Praises glory and gratitude
belong to him
um and I want to thank brother anas may
Allah bless him um and also the other
team members brother Abdul Kareem who's
doing the work brother uh jabby and also
I want to thank the core producer which
is my wife who helps me we have very
severe debates at home but we come to
conclusions and agree to disagree
sometimes I punch I'm joking
that's a joke of course
um anyways so bitter bosses there's four
bitter buzzers if any of you guys
disagree with anyone else you
you have one and a half minutes without
being interrupted to speak
other than that just to address a couple
of people who might be a bit uh jahid
who are like look at these people who
are Phoenix and uh which we also touch
with sadly yeah um our honorable sisters
who are here who are at the back our
honorable brothers are here who practice
who fear Allah
um you are slandering by choosing us
with your jahid no knowledge
um but we are here remix
we are here for the sake of Allah and
for that purpose only inshallah and
that's it today's topic is very very
interesting because I actually got a
message
from a brother that I kind of know he's
newly married he says first night with
his wife and here is the message that
was sent by his wife's friend who is a
female warning her to not
have intimacy with his own wife I'm
gonna read it out for you guys yeah you
guys ready
here this is how it goes okay the topic
is should should married couples have
single friends
that's the topic yeah and here is I'm
going to read it as much as I can give
some context okay so here is how it goes
okay
I'm calling you this is what she's
saying yeah and she goes I can't speak
as I am in the Uber don't want him to
understand Lord okay
and then she goes you know I heard
laughing and then she mentions to her
now you need to answer now it's very
important don't do the deed meaning do
not consummate the marriage yeah okay
then she goes read above like super
important so now this sister who's
married to this is probably saying
excuse me like expression question mark
like what's going on then she goes see
this period is getting to know period so
she's saying this period is against one
period yes honestly says everything they
said to me made sense I will explain to
you properly via record inshallah the
guy basically if you make it easy now he
won't see you as someone who is worthy
for him if he if that makes sense he
needs to earn your wovens so this is a
married woman who has been married and
her friend is telling her do not you
know consummate the marriage
and she goes are you serious with a
laughing emoji yeah she goes absolutely
well why they woke me up we don't know
who they are by the way is the
Illuminati is it aliens we don't know
who they are yeah
um I will explain to you properly viral
Court
okay now I've seen that I'm sorry and
then she goes absolutely why they woke
me up and she goes I see your point I
think maybe not to be awkward but I
won't refuse my husband it's his hug may
Allah bless the wife she's got some
common sense yeah then the friend goes
mentions her name and goes especially
was like you're basically thinking make
okay that doesn't make sense sorry yeah
try postpone it as much as possible to
get to know him better they both said
even till now they don't think their
husbands will you only get to know them
well when a situation happens when you
need them
Etc and whether they step in or out at
that moment so they so they stress how
one should put their feelings aside
and wait for the right moment also you
never know at any moment there's a
possibility of you conceiving so you
need to be ready for it
then she goes the wife goes let's go
I'll call you tomorrow and properly talk
about it yes I'm sorry yeah but we have
to give context definitely inshallah so
much going on now this is what she says
yeah it's I know it's difficult thing
but you really should think about it
honestly you're still at the beginning
stage and you don't want him to say
Halas I finally have her fully you would
like that to happen in the future no
like near to the willima unless you
absolutely have no desire to having a
willima now this is what the wife says
says calm down my love my husband is
super comforting and reasonable I don't
have any reason to be oppressive too
trust me it's all good now the message
continues on and on and on and she's
saying you know don't consummate the
marriage for three months four months
whatever it is yeah
now I don't know what you guys make out
make it to me yeah okay but the question
that needs to be asked is the following
should married couples have such single
friends is this and by the way I want to
make some disclaimers please let's try
not to buy the system whoever is that's
doing this it might be some genuine
concern it might not be it might be
jealousy whatever it may be watch you
guys make it out from a sister's
perspective that another sister wanting
another sister who just got married is
this jealousy is this a genuine concern
and the brother said to me very clearly
and directly he paid 9 000 pounds worth
of gold he's gone to the father and
spoken he's done he's paid Maher cash
and he's doing it
but this is this warning her friend as
if she's in a her own relationship what
do you guys mean here make out
sister that's our sisters is this a
jealous friend what is this pizza I want
to know
I think to start off we need to go back
to understanding how important it is to
have a circle and friendship around us
that is for us and islamically and even
psychologically it really does say and
talk about how important it is to vet
and filter your friends so that whether
they're single or not they are there
where you can turn to or they can turn
to you in the best way forward
especially when it comes to you seeking
for their advice or guidance and things
like that they are actually fit for it
and this seems to be where I would not
even give this person attention
um to respond so much if that was
actually done to me because I would know
that that's not necessarily for my
benefit but a lot of people are taken
away by their friends and they do they
do listen and they are enabled
um so it really does show a character
um of somebody who has a friend like
that and keep said and also seeks
guidance from it and I personally
wouldn't give attention to someone like
that especially on my wedding night
okay interesting um scissors
before I start uh just a little bit of
interaction about myself because uh my
name is I'm a mom to two on the 200 luck
I'm currently studying abs-c in
Psychology I've been in my third year I
do part-time teaching um teaching the
Arabic language Quran and Islamic
Studies two girls ages 7 to 18. I also
conduct a weekly classroom soup where I
mentor and discuss different topics
starting mental health from a secular
Islamic perspective at Alberta Institute
um to answer your question I think there
has to be boundaries with friends
um
they need to know that whatever goes on
between you or your husband the business
to be honest it's your personal life
um the problem is that sometimes the
people that we should be most close to
must open to our own spouses we don't
share with them openly but we're willing
to take advice from people around us
whether they be friends or family
um you know as a previous episode
mentioned as well the husband and wife
should try and have a good Mutual
understanding and everything is
reciprocal so you can't really predict
what's going to happen on your wedding
now what's not going to happen it really
depends on how things work out and if it
works out for you alhamdulillah if it
doesn't then you know there's plenty of
time in life and you could always go on
things okay well sister uh
yeah but you've got a friend here now
who's basically now you need to think
about islamically they are married this
probably look this this sounds crazy to
me that this man has given nine thousand
pound of gold well best believe that guy
seriously mad I'm giving I think three
or five thousand pound in cash he's gone
to the father he's done in the car but
if he's gonna buy all legit and then
you've got this friend who is coming now
and saying no no no no no you know you
should you should wait because
understand that to me this is toxic
femininity listen to me hajib is very
strange to me so reading that do you
think is there some kind of jealousy
involved because I personally believe
there's a theory I might be wrong I'm
often to be corrected I think this comes
more from the sister side that we should
I would personally say should married
women have single friends because from
our Circle I don't think any brother can
come I mean I've been first position for
a long time he would never seem to come
and say oh bro by the way yeah I was
feeling like you can't have this
discussion how's it going like your wife
Etc but never crossing the lineup bro
make sure you don't do this so he makes
me goes ah bro you know you knew they
got married so these don't happen with
men so do you think this is a sister's
issue where there's Genesee involved
because I can see uh forgive me I was
just looking I saw one two three four
heads nearly not so there's a reason
it's nothing please can you tell the
sisters because it seems like we're
missing something as men the bitter trip
sure well I want to understand the
opposite gender better so please tell us
why you're all not in your heads because
this is It's a phenomena yeah
that's not even on friends you know that
that right there is a woman who's
delusional she's more of an enemy to her
than she is to a friend and I think this
is why women have to be so so careful
about who their classes friends and just
because a friendship has lasted less
than 10 years you're now like in like
you're told the 14th year it doesn't
mean it's supposed to last a lifetime
sometimes people you know you're
supposed to let go of them because they
fulfill their purpose in life when a
person becomes toxic and you know
subhanallah the person is all right
she's toxic she's obviously giving her
the wrong advice
it's a sign you gotta let that person go
and I think a lot of women when they are
friends for so long they almost feel
like I now have authority other my
friend therefore she must do
um as I say and when that doesn't happen
they will manipulate her they will call
her any name that they possibly can to
get her to almost like become submissive
and fall into her trap but yeah no to
answer your question that's 100 jealousy
right there yeah I agree with the start
of the I think that's what we do
sometimes
um unfortunately like a bit of drama and
can go around that as well I think it's
just important that we try to keep our
married lives as private as possible and
if need be to get help go get
professional help go to Elders of the
family not friends who are not haven't
even experienced it's almost like
um we were talking about this the other
day but if I had like let's say you know
some sort of disease and would I go to
someone who's not a doctor to ask for
like medical advice so similarly if
you're not married sorry if your
friend's not married you know there's no
point of seeking advice from that and if
they generally have concern that there's
always a way to go around it so they
will come from a place of you know
General concern you could tell by a
person's body language and how they
communicating is that they're really
concerned for you and then obviously you
can you know take that consideration
then
we'll make a point uh just to play The
Devil's Advocate I agree with everything
you guys are saying
um I think with this particular sister
from the text message there was a part
that you said she said
um uh she said they were right so I get
the impression that that sisters most
probably divorced and she's had a really
bad marriage and whatever it is so she's
using her own personal negative
experience and projecting it onto that
sister as a poster I got from my
perspective I don't think his jealousy
might not be the root of it it might be
just someone who's had a very negative
experience and he's just trying to warn
her friend not to say that's an
appropriate advice at all because
ultimately what her advice should be is
positive and been affirmative and make
the eye shall I do what's right and that
kind of thing so oh generally the advice
I would say is completely wrong and the
married sister should now realize like
the other sister said um you know
there's a time and a place where certain
friends you hold on to so if you if
you're still seeing single I guess
there's things that you can relate to
and that friendship is valuable but if
you're now married and you're either
your friend is either divorced and you
as an individual or you know what she's
been through a really bad marriage I
want to avoid anything because I might
be influenced by that or just simply
because yeah just simply because I will
never thought a sister would buzz on her
sister mashallah okay or simply because
um it could be that
um you know she's not she's not married
now so she won't really add any value to
your relationship so therefore you
wouldn't really give her the air time
for any advice on marriage but I just
come from that angled by the technical
City it seems like someone that's been
through a bad patch and is just
projecting but he lost interest very
balanced Melody sister uh I I really
pressed it for one and a half minutes
okay I respect everything that you've
said however there's something that
we're doing here we are categorizing all
single women into one and divorce during
also into that just because she is
single does not mean she's a bad friend
I saw one Amity will see and I'm also
single but I Allah he will never give
any bad advice to any sister and I've
been through my fair share of trauma but
I've healed from that trauma and I'll
make sure to do everything I can that
that sister does not do anything that I
did wrong or that I learned from that so
it's not whether she is single whether
she is divorced is women in general
that's the issue here I think women
create that drama they love that
Authority and power and of course social
media is a massive role to play in this
but it does not I'm sorry nobody can
ever say that it's single women
therefore you cannot have single women
friends because my friend when I was
married she was single and she so many
times saved my marriage it still broke
so that's a different story but she
saved from breaking simply because she
was single yeah so you might not have
the knowledge but it comes out to how
wise you are how much of the sun on the
Quran that you know how much of good
principle and values you are and
honestly like how clean your heart is
because you you might not have
experience but if you can like mentally
put yourself in that position and be
like okay what would I do here that's
that's really saying something about a
person and that's something that
equality we don't see in women these
days am I allowed to respond yeah please
my by the way you you have a we're going
to go to the official account um you
have the buses by the way um so you can
use it one time so if you ever actually
yeah yeah um I'm not sure what we
disagreeing on because what I'm saying
is regarding the single sister about
divorce basically yeah because he's a
category
divorce you know there's a problem with
you yeah especially as women and I also
second but in the context of that sister
and her tongue but we don't know that
she does no yeah because that was a
speculation there was something that
actually said we speculated that she is
now um she's divorced yeah yeah she's
not inhaled we made something
divorce they have no rights to speak or
say and you have to be in a long-term
marriage which is successful which I
know a lot of long-term marriages so I
want to talk yeah are not actually that
fulfilled because I actually coached
them so at the end of the day we have to
be very careful when we're trying to
judge divorcees and it's not always the
woman's fault at the end of the day but
if you were divorced and you went
through a really bad trauma I am in that
situation yeah I was in that situation
to actually heal and help others and
also educate myself okay so there's a
difference yes okay saying that divorcee
shouldn't give advice it's not about the
same noise
we cannot come and say for example that
divorce sisters for some reason they
have this like no deal or whatever it
might be okay exactly yeah yeah yeah
whatever you feel like
it always happens with the women
yeah you know in high school they didn't
do that yeah so the thing is that you
know you run away from Mr lurgi monster
yeah so the thing is here is that that's
not the case you know alhamdulillah
divorce sisters like you guys said you
healed Etc but she has a point in the
context of you talked about being healed
well I'm good but sometimes before that
process sometimes there can be bitters
it can be heard and by the way this can
be with men as well they can be a man
and by the way the red pill movement
there's a there's a movement called
mgtow God men going their own way that's
what it's called the mgtow okay and this
these are toxic men who have had bad
experiences and are like with warning
and this is the reason why they hang
with this you know I've even uh bought a
book actually from uh Myron Scott
actually why a woman deserve less yeah
okay
but he actually his book is called why
women deserve less so a lot of the times
maybe certain traumas they might have
triggered this there's a lot of facts in
the book not totally but the point is is
she wrong for saying that maybe the
sister has had a divorce had a bad
divorce and she is projecting
yeah but it could also be maybe she's
got a very bad childhood maybe it's got
nothing to do with the divorce but we've
speculated we've jumped the gun here and
that's what I'm saying cannot do that no
I I said that because she said
um something if I if I heard everyone
she said they they they warned me and
they were right
as Ali said it could be aliens okay okay
okay
it's definitely not aliens but the thing
is that it means it could be Illuminati
yeah yes okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna
just get back on the top again I'm gonna
go through the message if I'm not
mistaken this might no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no
myself I'm gonna read it myself I'm
gonna see if it's a married couples I'm
gonna see if this comes from married
couples because if I'm not mistaken she
refers to these people who are married
who who are married and they they are
the ones who are warning her that their
husbands have changed or something like
that so maybe it's not from a divorcee
but it's from a married sisters who are
telling this sister to tell her friend
that when we gave intimacy early on this
is what happened which is absolutely
nonsense but anyway the men have been
quiet uh Brothers uh bro it doesn't
matter if she's married or forced to
wear yeah I don't know why we're trying
to categorize it like maybe she's
married maybe she's not who cares don't
mind
yeah maybe she's married or not it
doesn't matter up first and foremost I
felt like everyone should be changing
their energy and actually thinking how
bad this is for the brother no one's
actually thought about this brother now
imagine this brother I think I'd done
this last time
this guy let's just say he's in London
right where the rates of living are Sky
High and have rocketed up right and now
you tried to say you're not you can't do
anything illegal to make money martial
law because we're on a Halal straight
off it's another things we've got to
consider I'll do a lot of youth work and
a lot of brothers get uh called simps
have you seen that video that's really
annoying by the way get it called Sims
for not being able to provide so robbers
left the road life which is very easy
for him to do for example let's say he
goes and works a Halal job he's saved up
all that money when he didn't really
necessarily have to
yeah but to protect yourself from Haram
he's gone out of his way to go and meet
uh his wives his current wife's family
and father not necessarily an easy
process for anyone that's been married
it's not really easy is it it's very
challenging especially if you've got a
father that's going to grow you and ask
you about your record and where you've
come from about your childhood it might
be quite triggering he's gone through
all of these barriers green light green
light green light he might have had a
few red lights here in there green light
green lamp he's finally now paid down
how much is it 9k 9k worth of gold 12K
yeah 12 000 pounds yeah quick math quick
math problem and then what four Cat four
grand in cash
okay
and his brother's here and his lovely
wife is there and then she's got a
friend that's messaging these types of
advice here this is crazy now I know
people are probably thinking what's the
point the point is imagine if the wife
done what many women do do and men do of
take your friends wise imagine she'll
start you know what for real I'm gonna
make him wait oh my God
this is what this is how my like you
said this is how my runs are born this
is how like red pill movements are born
bro people keep saying you know you just
need to be your own person to be a role
model and not let life change you life
can change you I'm gonna be I'm gonna be
real if I went through that experience
so I saved saved up nine bags or
whatever in the same scenarios that
brother
and then my wife was refused him to you
know to consummate the marriage with me
this might just trigger something
because I'm just gonna say you know what
and this is why a lot of brothers do
this I'm never getting married again if
I do find a woman I'm not going to treat
her like this Prince like I treat disco
like a princess
I'm not gonna go and speak to hawani I'm
not saying I'm going to do this by the
way but it's it's a fool that can easily
slip into the Mind nobody no human likes
hardship no one likes hardships and now
it's like he's thinking well I went and
done it the right way and it never
worked out so I might as well do it the
wrong way and actually get something out
of it so
my point here was
basically poor problem and secondly
that's poor brother and secondly just um
bro I have friends that I will not take
advice from with anything in my life and
I've got friends that I will take advice
from whether they're married or not like
the sister said bad advice is bad advice
so clearly clearly this
this advice is bad I don't I don't think
it stems down to the title of this
podcast should marry people or should
married women have single friends then
you can have as much single friends as
you want I don't think they should be
able to uh Sidetrack you from fulfilling
your rights as a woman
I personally think
um it's a question as well although I
personally think that
yes people can't whether it's a man or a
woman you can have single friends that's
absolutely fine you you're you know
you're allowed to have friends you can't
tell your wife or you can't have friends
I you know I know people have
experienced that with their parents you
know they've said oh well my mum you
knows her my dad said that my mum can't
have any friends and she can't go out of
someone so who are you going to talk to
if you don't have friends other than
your husband you can't talk to your
husband about everything
this is my question of course good
friends but this is my question
and a statement at the same time I don't
think you should have anyone involved in
your marriage regardless of who is
whoever it's your friend your mum your
dad your brother your cousin I don't
think anyone should have an opinion on
your marriage because it's your marriage
it's no one else's marriage it's your
marriage so if I if I you know
inshallah I get married next year I want
to get married next year my my message
she was Catholic before
um before she became Muslim so we got
engaged right now we're not we're not
ready to get married but next year we've
done in the cabin
thank you I appreciate that but um but
yeah no I I don't think you know going
on my point marriage whatnot and someone
comes up to me and says Mick you know
what you know I don't I don't know I
don't think you know I don't think you
should do this I don't think you should
do that I'm just gonna ignore you bro
because at the end of the day you may
mean well but it's my marriage you don't
know what goes on behind closed doors
you don't know what we talk about you
don't know that the troubles and and
stuff that we've gone through together
like in in recent years whatever it is
and you've come to me and said oh Mick
you know I don't think you should do
this how do you know
I have personal experience with with
with people not coming up to me but
watching watching brothership behind
closed doors yeah having a having like a
snakey sort of like view on things I
thought or or looking at our brothers
what intentions bad intentions like in
what we're talking about here we're
talking about to break up your
relationship because are you talking
about it may not be it may not be it's a
breakup normal
but the Dynamics are different as they
must imagine the Muslim circles yeah
um do we get Brothers like I'll be
honest I don't ever remember going to
any of my friends and like yeah listen
you know it's your wife that we don't go
into them but I still as if that's what
they were nothing they were all naughty
ah nah actually now you're what no okay
Mike you're right no you're right I know
how you're right no you're right yeah
yeah trust me yeah the reason you're at
so it's cut off I think the reason you
won't find among Muslims is because you
know the ladies they have they have
modesty they cover up and whatnot a lot
of the men they can't you know they have
nothing to they have nothing to wow
embarrassed as a man to talk about to
talk about your wife you know of course
it's respectful that why why are you
thinking about it
they'll be a fight they'll be killing
they'll be there's people that died
come on brother trust me yeah
I'm talking about like this sister done
it in the terminal which most Muslims do
I'm just giving you advice inshallah
it's not nice advice but I'm just saying
any brothers here I don't feel like
neither of us would go to one another
and say Aki look this is what you've got
to do in your marriage I don't know
about killing them but it's really rude
isn't it what's the word it's like like
what I mean it's not what I mean is if
somebody has the audacity to come to me
and start saying listen yeah like in a
certain way I would say first thing
firstly why crossing your boundaries now
you didn't understand bro there's two
ways that can go yeah bro please don't
talk about my wife again and he's gonna
say but why this is about I just ask you
a nice thing now but you're talking
about that yeah
bro bro you can turn from something like
this yeah to to drive by
[Laughter]
you
all right so the the thing is first and
foremost it's very important for us to
understand that the prophet Allah said
to the nearest million that we should uh
seek religious knowledge everybody
should be armed with the basics of Islam
should be armed with the basics of
marriage there are countries like
Indonesia that actually make you do a
course before you get married yeah so
over here God's not you so over here
it's very important that a person that's
getting married you are going just like
when you're at work there's always going
to be people giving you differences
different views different opinions wrong
opinions good opinions you need to be
armed with the absolute Basics before
jumping into a relationship in which you
are now responsible for another adult
for another person yeah and your actions
can affect that person for the rest of
their lives so it's incredibly important
that you know that if you're getting bad
advice that firstly you're able to
design it as good good or bad advice and
number two you seek sure and sure as
something that's talked to us in the
Quran which is you don't just ask one
person yeah you ask a few people and
they need to have certain criteria as
well number one they need to know about
what you're talking about for example if
you talk about marriage they if they've
got maybe some Alum of psychology or
counseling or whatnot they're good and
they need to have a basic understanding
of the religion that's preferable
otherwise you know things can go here
and there so they need to have some fear
of Allah
secondly having a single friend is like
saying can a teacher ask advice from
somebody that's not a teacher of course
they can is that advice going to be
informed is it going to be valid it
depends what you're asking for are you
asking from a psychological point of
view or something if you're just asking
someone who's a child for advice then
you're an idiot frankly yeah you
shouldn't be asking a child uh sorry I
looked at you and when I said
it's okay it's okay individual so
so so in that super sense I mean uh you
should have yeah you should have sense
yourself as well and you shouldn't
really be seeking advice from people
that that don't really know but having a
single friend one thing I would say that
somebody actually accused me of this as
well anytime I gave advice that person
was saying oh yo you're single oh you
don't know but you don't have to be a
drummer to know what a drum kit is yeah
you can sometimes give an out of the box
View and non-biased view that people in
marriage or people that
institutionalized they would be thinking
in a certain way but you being a single
person can see things from a different
angle and it's up to that person to
decide if that advice is useful is
creative or is it destructive for me
okay it doesn't sound like that sister
even asks for advice it sounded like
this is what I'm saying well I don't
want to ask you somebody's do you work a
lot in the Muslim Community because it
comes across like you do that's sadly
yes
why do Muslims I'm talking like I'm not
Muslim but I'm just not in that world
it's so obligatory just to give advice
that wasn't asked for
that's actually a good point chicken no
no that's a good point because sometimes
it's like the advice that is in marriage
books and that's given to men yeah and
the advice is that when your wife uh or
or a woman like your mother or sister is
talking to you sometimes they they're
not really looking for advice yeah they
just want to talk they just want to get
out and they're not looking for logic
about understandably men are very
logical we're very kind of systematic
women are tend to be emotional they
don't tend to be very rational and
methodical like men so sometimes they
might be on your face no no this is
standard science yeah it's pretty
standard stuff yeah so so the thing over
here well I lost an attorney thanks a
lot yeah so yes okay it's not like a
giving advice sometimes doesn't
necessarily have to be telling that
person what to do it could just be
listening and it could just be nodding
along and saying you know what you've
had a very hard day and this and that
you know what should we do this or
should we do that like cognitive
behavioral therapy and stuff like that
is sometimes getting the person to just
talk and just maneuvering the person
around what they're going through so
they can reach a solution by themselves
and a a sensible Muslim brother if he's
speaking to another Muslim brother he
should know how you are and then like he
should know a bit about you and then
mold that advice around your temperament
if he's just telling you and you don't
like being told what to do and he's just
telling you yeah you don't like talking
being told what to do yeah don't do this
and don't do that that brother is not
very kind of clued on he needs to do it
in a more catered way if he is not able
to do that and that brother's really
paying you off then maybe you know find
a brother that is more kind of
understand standing to kind of your
energy and stuff a lot of people don't
know how to vet for that because I am a
cognitive behavioral therapist I do NLP
I'm doing my Master's in neuroscience
and site and psychology of mental health
I have been studying uh human mind and
behavior for the last seven years
Non-Stop and at the end of the day it we
don't give advice as a professional we
give guidance like you mentioned and
secondly it is a problem amongst the
women Muslim women do talk to their
friends about personal issues that they
shouldn't that's something I can
definitely say and they also talk about
um you know their marital issues a lot
whether it's their girlfriends whether
it's their sisters and things like that
and I don't think that that is actually
for their benefit because they're not
getting the right sort of feedback it is
projection a lot of the times it is from
someone's own sort of experience and
that's probably a negative one because I
hear it and I see it and then when
someone comes to me even as a friend or
a client and I'm like listen you do not
go that way or they've come to me after
they've taken that advice and they've
gone completely the opposite direction
of what they entail to so yeah you have
to be very careful but unfortunately
there is a problem about you know women
generally that do talk more than they
should especially about relationships
and they shouldn't that's a very good
point and it's good you brought it up
otherwise we probably wouldn't avoid out
because yeah because that's it's a
different topic but because we've
started it like the brother kind of
alluded to as well the thing is you know
your husband and your husband knows you
so when you will talk about your issue
most often statistically speaking and
even psychologically speaking you're
going to be putting yourself and digging
yourself up and helping that person down
more so yeah and the thing with that is
you're not really giving a complete kind
of picture and this is what they say to
teachers and that's what they say to a
sensible mediator as well always and
please I cannot emphasize this enough no
matter how bad it sounds please please
listen to both sides yes even if it's
really bad it's really terrible do not
please do not advise them and start
telling them to cut it off yeah if a
person has not heard both sides and they
are telling you to leave that person you
leave that person yeah because that's
not what we should be hearing at the
moment we need to be hearing people that
will delve deeper and that will like the
brothers came to join not to break and
sometimes people tend to you don't know
how well the person can communicate so
they might be kind of missing certain
facts out they might be look good at
articulating there might be other issues
that that person has missed out because
it's going to embarrass them so when you
speak to somebody else again don't speak
to just any old individual go to a
mediator in which both of you can sit on
the table and both the thing is here I
understand what you're talking about a
couple going through issues oh she's not
going through no issues bro yeah you're
dealing with someone I understand
no what I'm talking about is that you
know what you're talking about oh the
message yeah we're talking about
something else yeah but the topic I have
to bring about no it's bring it back
don't say like what we said in the topic
is wrong say okay let's bring it back to
the topic you shut your mouth
[Laughter]
no no we spoke is the Hub but what I'm
saying is this Pro that what you're
seeing is for couples come on for
couples who are going through Madness
yet they just newly bloody married Bro
that to me is very very achievable right
it's very very strange that number one
she didn't ask number two you as if your
nose you even know they just got married
now they just got married now and then
and you message and imagine how specific
you must be it's that James Bond bro
it's like oh now you know they're going
to their hotel and now you're much
better just the Friends the problem is
also you have to ask that person who is
listening and telling them how does that
person know you have to take
accountability no but that's it for
everybody you know that that person has
invited that friend into that
conversation by telling them she's way
too comfortable yes you you've let your
friend get way too powerful and intimate
in a relationship because she said this
sister was on point it's always bro if
it was somebody else's wife it would
have been oh it would have been Peak
yeah this this time she goes she goes I
fear Allah regarding my husband I'm not
gonna impress him yet at least she's on
point eventually there's another system
going you know what she's emotionally
saying oh my gosh maybe it's protein can
you imagine how how do you ruin their
first night when they're there then
she's swinging in the back of her head
oh is this guy going to use me and just
leave me or what kind of knocks is this
is that message even happening at that
that's what I'm saying but that's the
point
there is no boundaries but the point is
that can you imagine that how
psychological we already have shaytan
giving us what was about I don't need
another human shaytan yeah already
dealing with this and that and then
you've got somebody else who's supposed
to be a friend telling you oh be careful
before you be careful with your husband
but that to me is I'm dead what would
happen What would happen if somebody
told the man his his friend told him if
somebody told him don't give don't don't
give love to your missus well well
there'll be World War II there would be
World War I told but but thanks to a man
sex to a man is love yes so when you
take when you're taking away that love
you're taking away an integral part of
that relationship in fact it's and we're
going to talk about this on another show
on another episode hopefully but sex to
a man is is something that number one
but these are number one is being
bastardized yeah it's been bastardized
and nothing it means it means sorry I
looked at you again when I said that Ali
so it
was it
since we're talking about friendship
this is very unique so we're okay with
that yeah yeah what is the world
bastardize means it means when you've
turned that word into like a yeah like a
swear word like a disgusting sort of
thing but the way is like that's a
biological imperative to a man is one of
the strongest forces on the planet and
if it's and if has if if it has not been
kind of dealt with and answered and done
the correct way it can cause chaos on
the planet true yeah and the thing is
that this is love to a man if if he is
showing uh his his newly wed wife love
and affection and she's saying uh no
thanks uh I'm not gonna do it frankly
ill and that sort of stuff bro that's
mad to a man bro that's Pete
you get it so it just shows that for
example that for example in Islam the
fact that the man has to meet the father
uh speak to them get ruled by them
whatever it might be then Mahar and then
wedding that man is in Allah's put a man
in such a responsibility and in this
things that we need to do this protocol
it shows how valued Allah has made the
Muslim woman that as a Muslim man I have
to go through all these obstacles bro
speak to the dad they speak to the
brother and then arrangements
and by the way you have to announce it
it shouldn't be hidden we're going to
discuss a secret life soon that's a
different topic um but all of this stuff
it just shows how Allah is valued the
Muslim woman to such a degree that the
man has to work hard to get hurt I'm
trying to say and then you've got
somebody who is actually done
who has gone to this level given Maha
done all of this and then there is
somebody whispering in his wife's ear oh
don't Ajit but let's talk about
Solutions after this yeah uh just
because I felt like oh yeah since I'm
the host uh can you get up
so the thing is
so okay let's let's be a bit serious
because it's very being serious we've
been seriously no no I can't get kicked
out it's my show so look there's one
thing that's that's very important and I
want you to add this in a it kind of
links to the topic just in case
somebody's thinking look this is to do
with confirmation of the marriage
they've just just about got married and
that's a big Topic in itself like some
people might be thinking are you saying
that on the first night marriage has to
be consummated and stuff like that yeah
it's a different topic and the thing is
look that's up to that's up to the
discretion of of both people that if the
marriage has taken place and you know
the whole day you guys have just been
doing
um just marriage stuff and dealing with
guests and stuff like that not to rush
it uh inappropriate not to just rush it
as an act and if that's something that
both of you can agree upon and say look
because some people don't know each
other very well like it's an arranged
marriage so if you want to take a day or
two to just get to know each other or
stuff like that then that's something
you can do as is what but because it was
talking about but wasn't that it's
important to mention any case you're not
talking about I wasn't on the first
night though yes but that's not the
distance no no no it's not the
discussions but we mind she's saying the
William is a free month making weight
yeah yeah no no three months that's
something else but what I'm saying is
that this is also part of the discussion
as well because we did say that look sex
is very important blah blah blah but
yeah as soon as the past is married
there are certain kind of things that
you guys can agree upon that the three
months thing is ridiculous in fact that
message was a parody in itself I was
this ridiculous bro oh that's how long
it took you to read that message bro
that's it yeah another one can I decide
um I'm sure there's a Hadith it's not
coming to me exactly in mind
um that you should leave married couples
alone for three days or something like
that where you don't yes given that
privacy so if for example the person
given that advice was following the
Islamic principle there and the person
receiving their advice reminded that
person to say look this is my time you
know I shouldn't be contacted or
something like that so I think he also
goes done to the fundamentals of knowing
their boundaries like you know the
sister said that you know
um you know for all married couples and
maybe something that we do need to
encourage our young girls to talk about
this to their friends approaching
marriage that don't you know and tell
your friends like do's and don'ts yeah
because the friends got married recently
and I said give him space you know
Islamic human to give him space and
stuff like that so I think just creating
that culture as opposed to the jahili
culture which is oh my God you know did
you do it the first night and you know
that kind of girly girly relationship
that we actually move away from that and
start instilling this in our girls from
a young age that don't discuss these
kind of things or if your friends
daughters get married you know someone's
getting married make sure you give them
that space don't talk about anything
intimacy and you know just to change the
culture around coming away from the
Japanese
to our kids we're going to start
wrapping up um so let's go with that
windshield that sister yeah I just heard
to say that um intimacy earth science is
quite an integral part of marriage that
is also one of the most leading causes
of divorces as well unfortunately
and
um I think a good way to sum it up is
that if your friends are gonna
emotionally blackmail you by saying that
you know if you don't tell us this that
we're not going to be friends with you
then you're just with the wrong friends
to begin with and also I think Fred
should understand that as you said as
everyone said here like boundaries and
um friends and also like family as well
like when some you know when the couple
gets married let them figure it out you
know give them space give them time and
they'll come back to you
um and Auntie actually said to me that
it's almost like when a newly couple
gets married is like you're figuring out
a new thing because like a new Venture
you don't know you figure out each other
and each other's Lifestyles and also um
I think it's also called detrimental
where people put themselves in other
people's shoes a big or because that
doesn't work for them
um it hasn't work for me sorry it is
working for them so that's wrong that's
like a red flag but that's not the case
because just you know they both have
their own understanding soon even like
as we talked about cookie clearly before
um
you know if the husband's happy that's
fine you know you know it's their
marriage or whatever doesn't matter
okay
um sorry
okay one second this is the framework
system and then
again to sum up I think it's really
important that we know how to vet our
friends and we can have long-term
friendships but there's a time and place
for everything and just to reiterate
it's really important that you don't
discuss these certain things at certain
times and I also would say it's not just
the person that's giving the advice in
this particular letter that you read out
I think it's also the person that's
allowing it to happen and you know
opening up those messages in the first
place and speaking to that person in the
in a you know in a moment where it
should be just between you and your
husband anyway so it's both that is
wrong in that sense and I think that we
need to be very careful
um because I know a lot of people
they'll even come and tell me that you
know a lot of their personal issues and
detailed stuff and what's going on and
that is not allowed that is not right
but that happens obviously as a
professional it's different but even as
friends when they're telling me that it
shouldn't be done but it is done and is
continuously done and it's actually
detrimental to you
so I didn't assistant summed it up
there's just three things I want to say
and the first thing is regardless of
who's giving you the advice take you
with a pinch of salt it doesn't matter
who it is whether it's your best friend
your mom your dad psychologist it
doesn't matter take it with a pinch of
salt because that person is not in your
shoes only you know your situation the
other thing I was going to say is
um take this as a really good reminder
an opportunity to look at yourself to
take some
take a moment to self-reflect what kind
of friend are you and what kind of
friends have you got in your circle
because it's not a case of okay I'll
drop her when I get closer to my
marriage or after I'm married but it's
more like look your friends can never
take you to Johanna or they could take
you to Jannah so it's really important
to look at who it is that is influencing
your mind on a daily basis and to the
sisters who feel inclined to always give
advice you don't always have to give
advice understand the cues where someone
wants advice that when somebody wants
just just wants a listening ear and I
think it's really important if your
friend is coming to you with issues
where you think okay maybe this isn't
really my place then don't say anything
don't just say something for the sake of
it because you know it's going to have
consequences just learn I think when we
need to learn to stay quiet we we can
talk literally all the time so learn to
stay quiet and know your time and place
when it is required for you to speak
appropriately exactly Michael
um just two really quick things
um as a man I wouldn't want to play tug
of war with my wife you know going back
and forth like her friends are secretly
telling her things in it yeah I'm gonna
feel like I'm playing tug of war like
between me and her friend and I don't
even know it I don't know it at this
point I don't know it and I'm pleased
you don't know why I don't know I don't
know what's what's being told I'm at
work I'm doing whatever it works she's
at home and she's she's thinking about
these things that she's been told by a
friend and I don't know it I'm fighting
Wars that I can't see I don't know how
to battle it I don't even know it's
there well let this assistant can you
imagine you're coming back from work
you're trying to provide you love your
wife
is the only pieces bro these are the
ones who cause marriages to break yeah
these little shout out teams who are
coming and yeah yeah does your husband
do this and you're coming home you're
not even beefing your wife bro you're
beefing her dumb friends I know and you
come home you come home you want to have
some time with your wife being a pack of
your wife's mind she's thinking about
the things her friends have been telling
her that aren't even true so now so now
your marriage will then suffer because
of because of people that don't actually
care about your marriage your marriage
is suffering because of them exactly
all I wanted to say was when it comes to
your friends her sister said take a
grain of salt it's not always it's not
always going to be the best advice it
may be there to you know keep you safe
it may be there because they love you
but sometimes it isn't always you know
and the final say for the chef you
so in in marriage typically speaking
women value love men value respect and
if you are talking behind the man's back
uh yeah it's disrespectful he doesn't
like his business being talked to other
people and strangers and then like the
brother said him coming home and having
to deal with that it's it's just
unnecessary if uh you want to solve the
matter speak to the person there's no
point speaking to somebody else because
you guys know your relationship better
if that person's not communicating then
that's the issue then that's what you
need to deal with look you're not
communicating with me look this is what
we need to deal with we need to take
time out then that's that's the thing
but ultimately speaking speaking behind
his back and if he finds out I'm telling
you that's going to be the cause of a
big row because he's gonna and you might
think oh it's something small I'm just
getting someone's opinion even they say
statistically speaking even when there's
a breakup women tend to speak to their
friends and get kind of support of them
men to tend to take short term so
solutions by just kind of drowning their
sorrows or just doing quick quick kind
of solutions so women do tend to
communicate so so that's the thing just
kind of you know stay around that
especially when you're in the kind of
marriage phase and just understand how
important respect is to your man and how
this can be seen as this disrespectful
that doesn't mean that now you don't do
anything at all like I've said I don't
want to be misconstrued but then if
communication is the issue then make
that and identifies identify that as an
issue and then that's your starting
point and it's a matter of trust as well
yeah as well to keep what you know
when's going on between ourselves
I'm under pressure so much but what I
say in the room and on the camera my
mind ends up going blank because I'm not
I had a really good point I'm like but I
gotta worry but now I've got the point
luckily as you interrupted right
the point was a tuplets was um number
one I just want to make it clear
especially for the viewers because I
heard Ali mentioned this earlier most of
us men don't really get out much I don't
get out and associated with hardly any
brothers so this is why we might have
been acting a bit boisterous so childish
so please there was no weird free mixing
or nothing going on it's going to make
that clear with this being always
unfortunately yeah
but one really important thing and I'm
not going to go into too much detail
because it might seem a bit
inappropriate however if we actually
think about it in Practical terms that's
sister that went and got married to that
brother and I'm guessing she didn't
consuming it uh course to make the
marriage right there and then
but when it was time to actually go and
do the deed
imagine how she was thinking I
guaranteed that advice from her friend
was going through her mind when that was
meant to be one of the most blessed your
sacred pure times that she was ever
meant to experience in her whole life
and then straight away this little you
call it a shaytan I call it a witch it's
witch that's casting her spell not this
specific system never say that yeah just
generally okay consider spell and when
God in Leviosa in our brain and now
she's thinking a b and c d and yeah the
evil eye evil mind bad man that's that
and the other thing was um I think the
sister here said it was
um and it's a really good point but I
don't think you are stressed it enough
yeah where you said this person
might not just represent a friend this
so-called friend here could also be uh
the Mother-in-law but aren't he even
your father even your friend brother
there are many mother-in-laws that do
these types of things it might even be
your own mum bro your own mum do you
know how many other mums have this crazy
weird obsession over their sons getting
married this is a big issue you need to
talk about as well bro did you yeah
come on next time when you talk about it
no but seriously just remember like the
sister said it's not always just a
friend it could be anybody giving you
these like dangerous seeds of advice
that will Sprout out and be something
very negative and you have some negative
fruits in your marriage
exactly well like amazing may I bless
you guys we talked about the problem we
talked about the solutions uh we talked
about iblies who are Whispering
um and causing corruption literally
Family household we're already under
attack Left Right Center lgbtqt we've
got flipping Jeffrey marshmallows on our
case yeah and then we're flipping
dealing with a little Charity instead of
to see whatever you want to call them
yeah you listen there uh give us what
somebody else protect us and hope you
guys learned something from the bitter
trip today inshallah and the whole point
of this show is may Allah bless our
honorable sisters who have who are
coming here giving their take on it
honorable Brothers
bless you and Shaquille we're gonna have
you guys more on the show inshallah
the next topic we're going to discuss
um is going to be secret second wives uh
okay I think the Y is going to kill you
but you know till next time
the prophet salallahu said whoever
builds a message for the sake of Allah
Allah will build for him a similar house
in Jannah on that day where Allah tells
us that our books will be given and
every little atom weight of God did
you've done will be there and imagine
you see a mountain and you're like what
an ucky person which righteous person
and Allah says this is for you for me
yes what did I do
you allow people to pray you built a
Masjid I've never had the money to build
a Masjid Allah
you helped you you gave towards it and
Allah gives you the reward of
death on it now guys and do not delay
and share the video for extra Rewards
foreign
[Music]